so some of you have rightly and
accurately pointed out to me that
suddenly florida's coronavirus cases
have started to decline
california's coronavirus cases don't
seem to be spiking the way the
trajectory suggested
and i started to look into this and
indeed it is true if you look at
florida their cases have started to drop
off
but it just so happens that florida
stopped testing this is no conspiracy
theory this is what they announced they
were going to do
because of the hurricane hurricane
isaias
as donald trump has struggled to say uh
look at this article from npr from july
29th
saying florida will pause coronavirus
testing due to impending storm
now it didn't happen all at once in all
of the counties so
we are still seeing thousands of cases a
day from florida but because different
counties
as the hurricane worked its way through
the state stopped testing
the numbers of tests went down
dramatically
and we can sort of turn to donald
trump's favorite phrase here
if you don't test you don't find cases
and that's true
the article saying quote after the
state's testing sites close
thursday evening that's last thursday
they won't reopen
until at least tuesday morning that's
yesterday that's according to candy sims
of the florida
department of health in broward county
so what do we do well one thing we can
look at is icu usage and you can see
that florida icu usage hit 100 percent
in the last week of july and it's still
there you can actually go over 100
percent
in that you can start to convert non-icu
spaces
in hospitals to temporary icu but they
florida has been stuck
at 100 icu usage for days
this is very very bad and i'm getting
more and more people saying
can we even trust the numbers now can we
trust the case numbers
can we even trust the death numbers
right now
and this is a real concern now part of
the concern
generally comes from the change that
happened from july 15th
into july 16th where hospitals were
mandated to stop reporting directly to
the cdc
and instead to the department of health
and human services
there are open questions as to if and to
what degree
that has influenced numbers in specific
states though
we know why the case numbers are going
down florida's one example
they stopped testing because of the
hurricane
let's look at california california now
is admitting that for days they've been
under reporting case numbers the
explanation is still not totally clear
and maybe by later today or tomorrow
we will know more about it but a message
appeared on california's covet 19
dashboard which said quote
due to the issues with the state's
electronic laboratory system
these data represent an under reporting
of actual positive cases
california's top health official dr mark
galley
said quote over the past few days the
state system we've discovered some
discrepancies so we're still waiting on
more information but
when you look at the globe the national
case numbers and you see that they seem
to at least have stopped increasing
understand that two of the major case
centers florida
and california are under reporting cases
one because they are
there they have stopped testing because
of a weather event california for some
unknown reason that they've discovered
discrepancies
and yet even with florida reducing
testing
even with california under reporting we
still had 54
000 new cases yesterday we still had
almost 49 000 new cases on monday so a
few different
thoughts on this cases aren't really
declining they've kind of leveled off at
the national level
but two states are under reporting and
that would be a huge piece of why that
is
so first off at this point it's very
hard to say for sure
whether cases are still growing
nationally or have leveled off or what's
going on
what we do know is that the big picture
the sort of fundamentals of what's
happening in the country haven't really
changed
so we wouldn't really expect a huge
decline because there haven't been any
big changes in policy now it's
conceivable
that even without states really changing
policy
that people are seeing the headlines and
they're being more cautious
that's possible it would take about 15
or so days
to notice that and increasingly deaths
are going to be the indicator to the
extent that we can trust them and if you
look at the trend line in terms of
deaths
the seven day moving average which sort
of smooths out those dips
of reporting that happen over the
weekend the death ra
rate and the death trends don't look
good they may have
maybe leveled off slightly but yesterday
again we had nearly 1500 deaths
so it's too early to say and then you
get to
are there ways to cover up deaths we
know that there are
you can mess with cause of death you can
do other other things so
the important message i think is
we're in an area now where there is a
question mark
around the accuracy of the data we don't
have to go conspiratorial we don't have
to make any definitive statements we can
just say
there are reasons to be skeptical of the
data including
that florida stop testing in california
is under reporting
so we are still at huge risk of even
bigger spikes when the united states
got from what was it 35 000 cases a day
down to 20 000
almost every state started reopening 20
000 cases we still had
and many states saw that as a license to
open and we got all the way back up to
70 000 cases a day
at one point about 10 days ago what we
can say for sure is
widespread reopening and ignoring risk
factors and risky activities and not
wearing masks
is going to create a completely out of
control spike
and just look at some of the headlines
from the last 24 hours teachers returned
to a georgia school district last week
260 employees have already gone home to
quarantine
not good uh dr fauci says if we don't
get below 10
000 cases a day before the fall we will
have an even more insane explosion in
the fall
and that's still 10 000 cases a day that
would mean we needed like an 80 to 90
reduction to get down to 10 000 cases a
day
clorox announces it will not have enough
disinfecting wipes
until 2021 according to its ceo
25 people have been infected at a bible
camp
in oregon when coronavirus subsided in
israel israel reopened schools it didn't
go well
and things are shutting back down this
is a real thing you know when trump says
it's the invisible enemy
it's this dumb thing he keeps repeating
the invisible scourge nobody telling him
it's pronounced
scourge okay but in a sense it can feel
as though it's not really there because
it is invisible
we see the results through our actions
our actions directly
impact these numbers to the extent that
we get the real numbers
and we need to be very cautious you know
i'm trying to take it in stride in the
sense that
my i can only focus on my sphere of
influence i can't control what everybody
in the country does i can't control what
the policy is
i can ensure that i'm acting as
responsibly as possible and at least to
you i communicate what seems to be
responsible
our actions have consequences and if
it's uh
i can't think of a time where it's been
more clear than it is right now i want
to talk today about the phrase
trump derangement syndrome i've tweeted
about this a few times
and chauncey de vega wrote a really good
article about this on salon which i
tweeted yesterday
called there was no trump derangement
syndrome we were right about him
all along so let's talk about this trump
derangement syndrome
is a bad faith phrase which is meant to
shut down debate
stop conversation and excuse donald
trump's atrocious behavior now
i know that there will certainly be some
of you who will respond to me and say
you know david look
check out this person on twitter who is
irrationally obsessed with everything
trump does and they think anything bad
in the world is trump's doing
this person is suffering from trump
derangement syndrome
listen you you can find instances of
everything on the internet but we're not
dealing in anecdotes here
the problem systemically with the phrase
trump derangement syndrome is that its
use is very similar
to what regressive left became a couple
of years ago i don't know if you
remember this
but regressive left much like trump
derangement syndrome are phrases that
are used to shut down debate
by disqualifying and dismissing
criticism
without actually having to debate the
merits of the criticism
so let's first really dig in i want
everybody to get this
what do people mean by trump derangement
syndrome the idea of
tds as it's sometimes called is
to use it as a retort when someone
criticizes donald trump someone says
look trump did this trump's not
responsible for 160
000 deaths but he's responsible for some
because it's been one of the worst
responses to the virus in the world you
have trump derangement syndrome
and what they mean by that is you are so
blinded by your hatred of donald trump
that we can dismiss
what you are saying without examining it
because you're just blinded by by your
rage against donald trump
so think back to the term regressive
left there was this very
very brief period where the term
regressive left
was sort of interesting in that it was
used to describe instances of ostensible
or supposed leftists failing to actually
be on the left in their views and
typically what what you had was
instances of people who claim to be on
the left being authoritarian and in a
sense it was a useful term for a very
short period of time and very quickly
the term regressive left
was bastardized and perverted by the
right and it became a catch-all insult
that they used
to basically say you're on the left and
i don't like what you have to say
uh i don't like what you're saying
because it's left wing and regressive
left lost all
value as as any kind of a useful tool
to explore failing to be on the left
trump derangement syndrome is equally
meaningless
with the important difference that
unlike regressive left
trump derangement syndrome never
actually described a real thing it was
always bogus there was a brief period
where regressive left actually was an
interesting
term to describe something i had been
talking about for for many years
which are instances of the authoritarian
left failing to really be on the left
but with each passing day the most
serious concerns about donald trump that
were expressed by people
on the left like me have been proven to
be true and they've been proven to be
true horrifyingly so remember that
months ago joe biden was widely
ridiculed for suggesting
you know trump might try to create some
kind of pretext an emergency of some
kind
to delay the election trump uh uh did
that
days ago by tweeting maybe we do need to
delay the election
joe biden was ridiculed and said he was
you know people were saying he has trump
derangement syndrome
he was right years ago people raised the
alarm
about donald trump's authoritarian
tendencies sort of he wants to be a
he's a wannabe dictator and over the
last month we have seen
him send armed paramilitaries to
american cities
to throw people into unmarked vans and
as chauncey de vega points out
points out in the article that we're
linking to which you should read quote
this was a phrase used to demean mock
reject
dismiss and deflect warnings about
donald trump's beliefs and tendencies
and those who were trying to raise the
alarm were called again as chauncey says
hysterical alarmist or out of touch
and bitter about hillary clinton's loss
if you encounter the phrase trump
derangement syndrome on the internet on
twitter
in real life maybe anywhere don't allow
yourself to be bullied into silence by
it
they claim on the right that they're all
about conversation
and yet this entire idea of trump
derangement syndrome is meant to stop
conversation make it clear that calling
someone a victim
of trump derangement syndrome is not
really an argument
say i'm glad to talk about that which
facts did i get wrong i'm glad to change
my views if you tell me what i got wrong
trump derangement syndrome is not an
argument it's a smoke screen it tries to
put us on the defensive
but the real derangement is the more
than 60 million people nearly 63 million
people who voted for donald trump in
2016.
tens of millions of whom plan to vote
for him again in just months
that's the real derangement the
horrifying nature of this presidency
which will be affirmed by 50 60
65 67 million people
who plan to vote for it again in
november if there is any
valid criticism of those like me on the
anti-trump side
it's that we didn't do enough to raise
the alarm prior to him being elected
as much as i tried now of course the
people who are primarily to blame are
the people who
fell for it and voted for trump but if
you want to make a criticism of the
anti-trump left that is to be taken more
seriously
criticize us for something real which is
that as much as many of us
were trying to warn people even we might
have
underestimated the risks of the
presidency that's
the reality trump derangement syndrome
don't allow it to be used
to silence actual critiques of this
president which if anything
have been not uh alarmist enough
let me know your thoughts i'm on twitter
at deepakman and remember you can get
the daily audio podcast
every day 3 pm eastern on your favorite
podcasting app whichever one it may be
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are
carrie mckay
and mary paulin thanks to carrie and
mary appreciate your support and also a
big
extra special thank you uh to daniel
brunk
daniel is today's long time sustaining
member of the day daniel's been a member
almost five years
and daniel uh i'm sure would tell you
you should grab a membership at
joinpacman.com
okay we've had a bit of a short break
from hatred mail due to breaking news
but i do want to get back to it what is
hatred mail
this is hatred mail between a renowned
infectious disease expert
and the guy who ran a fake university
and bankrupted a casino
i'm gonna have to go with the casino guy
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate david pakman
because america and because
freedom gotta love the new uh
relevant coronavirus introductions
um here is a very timely hatred mail
related to the race to one million
youtube subscribers take a listen i'm
not a fan of david
cuckold pacman do incels write your
headlines now
shame on you pacman what's terrifying is
that this guy
actually has an audience imagine if he
got to one million subscribers
youtube would be ended park man
cooking what a joke does pacman even
know
how to fry an egg this is a very real
risk i like how
you know if pacman if pacman gets to one
million subscribers i don't know
things could get really bad well it
seems to be more a matter of
when not if my goal is to get to a
million youtube subscribers before
election day this really would be a
major accomplishment what i was thinking
back to when we started the channel
and it took us like five years to get
our first hundred thousand subscribers
we are trying to get our last hundred
thousand well hopefully not the last
ever but the most recent hundred
thousand nine hundred to a million
um we're trying to do it in just about
three and a half months
and it would be a record and we've
already gone from nine hundred thousand
to nine hundred and seventeen thousand
and my prediction is there are going to
be many many hatreds
very very upset um sometime between
i don't know election day and the end of
the year between election day and
christmas let's say
when we roll over into the seven digits
for our youtube subscriber count
fight patriotism with something that
costs nothing just make sure you're
subscribed to the youtube channel
youtube.com
slash the david pakman show and i will
have updates for you right now we are
projected to reach a million on
december uh 23rd okay so we've got to
make up a little more ground and
reaching a million before election day
is actually on the table
so after the absolutely disastrous
interview with axios's jonathan swann
which went insta viral yesterday even
our clip by the way discussing the axios
interview
received nearly 600 000 views in the
first 15 or so hours we've never had a
clip go
viral this quickly donald trump needed a
gimme because that interview went so
poorly
so he's down but not out so what better
opportunity is there
for a safe softball interview for the
president
than to call into the sycophants
at fox and friends on fox news bright
and early this morning well
it didn't go well and because of all of
the attention already on donald trump's
interviews in general thanks to that
crazy embarrassing humiliating
performance on monday night with axios
people are even seeing the fox news
interview
barely had trump holding it together
this was meant to be a softball
interview for the president
and i want to look at some of the clips
because of all the top issues right now
that we are dealing with they all came
up during this interview trump on the
wrong side
tragically of every single one of these
issues i'm talking about coronavirus i'm
talking about opening schools
vote by mail trump's second term this is
a fox interview
and it went tragically bad for donald
trump let's get right into it i
predict you will be stunned and appalled
so to start with
donald trump was given a third
opportunity to say
what are your priorities if you get a
second
term and this is the third attempt from
donald trump to answer this question
and he still could not name a single
policy mr president what is your second
term agenda what are your top priorities
i want to take where we left we had the
greatest economy in the history of the
world we were better than any other
country we were better than
we were ever we we never had anything
like it in this country 160
million people working we've never had
that before we've never even come close
to that
best employment numbers best
unemployment numbers
for african-american asian-american
women
hispanic everybody the best numbers
we've ever had the best stock market
we've ever had although we're coming
very close right now in fact nasdaq is
already higher than
that number so a lot of good things are
happening that needs to be jobs
what i want to do is take it from that
point and then build it even better he
still can't answer it
donald trump got one chance at this
question during a town hall with sean
hannity
what are your second term priorities
named nothing
two weeks went by trump got a second
chance
during a tv during a phone interview
with sean hannity knowing that his first
answer was terrible
got a second chance at the same question
still couldn't name a single second term
policy
he now gets a third opportunity here
and is unable to list any policy he
listed races and ethnicities that's true
but unable to list any actual policy
that would be a priority in the second
term
trump once again in his obsession to
pretend that the country is back to
normal despite
another tragic 1500 deaths from
coronavirus yesterday 1470 something
like that
trump says schools should open now
and kids are almost immune which is of
course not true
what is your the latest on your view of
how these schools
should reopen my view is the school
should open
this thing's going away it will go away
like things go away and my view is that
school should be open
if you look at children children are
almost
and i would almost say definitely but
almost
immune from this disease so few it's
they've got stronger
hard to believe i don't know how you
feel about it but they have much
stronger immune
systems than we do somehow for this
completely irresponsible kids are kids
are almost immune and i would say
definitely immune he says that's wrong
um in fact there's a recent study that
found that there was a summer camp i
don't remember in which state
widely infected summer camp and they
grouped the infections by age bracket
the younger the kids the more likely
they were
to be infected and carrying coronavirus
so
you know it's funny to even frame this
question as what's your latest view on
this mr president because trump has no
idea he's the last person who should be
asked
for his opinion on these matters but he
happens to get it
completely wrong they keep going on
coronavirus and trump again cites
without any evidence that by election
day
coronavirus is going to be in really
good shape brian kilmeade presented
trump with the very real
um circumstances that a lot of older
folks the ones most at risk
are worried about voting in person in
november and trump says yeah things are
going to be really good
by november and of course remember that
donald trump said in march
that our 15 cases would soon be zero we
are now
about to hit five million cases in the
next couple of days
looking at the pandemic seniors and
those with underlying conditions are
most concerned about voting they could
be the most patriotic person in the
world
but even your age bracket mr president
they're concerned about going out in a
crowded area and it's legitimate
so having said that what does the
administration plan on doing to make it
easier
more poll sites clean teams making
demand demanding more uh
more places in in more areas providing
the financing to do that
so if we admit there's a pandemic and a
hurdle what do you plan on doing at it
if mail-in voting makes you unsettled
brian all of those things and more but
all of those things and remember
november third's a long way that's a
long way the numbers are coming down
very rapidly in florida
they're coming down in california
they're coming down in texas they're
coming down those three places shut up
and those numbers are coming down so by
the time we get there we'll probably be
in very good shape
but all of those things cleanliness
they'll wear
the mask they'll do whatever they have
to do but they want to vote
we have people that really want to get
out and vote it's going to be very safe
but by november 3rd that's you know time
wise that's
eternity frankly as far as i'm concerned
by the way trump says
cases are down in florida and california
we did a report on today's show already
about why that is
florida stopped testing on thursday
because of the upcoming hurricane isaias
and california admitted today yesterday
that they've been
under reporting cases for days and trump
cites that as evidence that things are
getting better so that's
wacky let's now go into vote by mail
the topic is the post office somehow
hillary clinton becomes the topic
hillary clinton accuses trump of
sabotaging the post office or sabotaging
i know some people prefer that
which they obviously are doing like
there's no question that when trump
appoints louis de joy
to run the post office as postmaster
general the idea is sabotage the post
office
and trump doesn't deny it he just
attacks hillary mr president uh thank
you for joining us you mentioned the
postal service well
your former opponent is out of the woods
or tweeting from the woods and this is
part of what
she said about the postal service and
your treatment of it
hillary clinton tweeting this i fear
republican
sabotage of the u.s postal service
including slowing mail delivery is a
trump strategy to make voting more
by mail more difficult this fall request
your ballots and return them as early as
you can
your response to hillary clinton
accusing you of sabotaging the post
office well first of all you know
remember the famous question when she
asked me whether or not i
accept the results of the election you
know she felt pretty confident
until the end of that debate and frankly
she was very strong do you would you
accept the results of the election well
she didn't accept the results she still
has she's living in a cocoon
and i guess people don't like her or
somebody doesn't like her but she was
she didn't do the job she didn't do the
job that she was supposed to do and she
should accept that
now she continues to go on and she's
talking now about the postal service
well
as you know the postal service for 40
years has had big problems
and they're not equipped to handle a
governor where they say millions of
ballots by the way will be posted
in a couple of weeks a gear up you can't
do that it doesn't work that way
it's a very complex process so nevada
we're in court we'll see how it works
out but if it doesn't work out
you're not going to know the november
3rd election results i'm talking for the
country
it could be for months and months i mean
actually it could be for years because
you'll you'll never
if they sent and they plan to send these
ballots to everybody that's ever walked
in the state of nevada
it will be a disaster did you sabotage
the post office listen
hillary hasn't accepted the results of
2016. people don't like hillary
she didn't do the job the postal service
has big problems they're not equipped to
handle ballots you might not know the
results for years
none of that is true but there's no
denial there from donald trump that he's
trying to sabotage the post office
hillary conceded the election
on election night trump keeps repeating
she hasn't accepted the results
he hasn't accepted the results he still
thinks he didn't really lose the popular
vote
she accepted the results on election
night the postal service
would be completely equipped to deliver
all of these ballots as long as trump
doesn't sabotage it
and of course it wouldn't take years to
know the election results but donald
trump does not deny
that he's trying to sabotage the postal
service because he's trying to sabotage
the postal service hillary clinton is
exactly right
then the topic of the republican
national convention comes up
now trump already announced they're not
going to do the rnc in person in florida
it's just too dangerous that's the right
decision
trump now says he might give his
rnc speech from the white house lawn
which would be
completely outrageous that's a political
event you're not supposed to do
political events at the white house
trump doesn't care and listen to the
reason he gives for doing it at the
white house
there are reports that you're
considering possibly giving your
convention acceptance speech from the
white house law what's the latest on
what you'll be doing for the convention
well we're thinking about it it would be
the easiest from the standpoint of
security you know they move with a lot
of people it's very expensive operation
militarily and and law enforcement wise
the secret service is fantastic
but you know it's a big deal and we're
thinking about doing it from the white
house because there's no movement
it's easy and i think it's a beautiful
setting and we are thinking about that
it's certainly one of the
alternatives it's the easiest
alternative i think it's a beautiful
alternative i love the building i'm
there right now
i spent a lot of time here a lot of
people didn't spend as much time i spend
a lot of time here and i like it
and i think it's a great place and great
greatly representative of our
our nation so it would be by far the
least expensive from the country
standpoint because it really is it's a
big deal
when you get up and move all of this
apparatus i
i really hope that you understand why
this is crazy
trump now says you know it's expensive
to move me around
secret service security big mobilization
taxpayer money
so i might do the rnc speech at the
white house lawn
trump golfed 284 days so far
during his presidency and every time
they do the full mobilization of secret
service and of trump staff
they rent every golf cart at mar-a-lago
or wherever trump golf's
it pours money into trump's businesses
and now
suddenly trump is concerned with not
wasting taxpayer money on moving him
around
so he's going to give the speech from
the white house lawn which is not a
place where political actions should be
taking place
you should be doing a convention speech
in a political setting
not on the white house lawn but golfing
284 days is a fine reason to mobilize
secret service trump doesn't want to
spend your taxpayer money though
going somewhere else for the convention
speech the guy can't even keep it
together on
fox news i was thinking last night and
this morning especially after seeing
these clips
what's fox news going to look like on
election night if donald trump loses and
you know never mind that what is trump
going to look like on election night if
trump loses
fox news may be you know we've been
covering fox news from the
from the perspective of its role in the
right-wing media echo
chamber for many years what would be the
impact on fox news of a donald trump
loss if one were to happen i think it's
an interesting question
and we'll have more clips and coverage
of this bizarre
fox news interview on the david pakman
show instagram
page david pakman show all one word on
instagram follow us there
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
welcome back to the david pakman show
so for anybody in my audience who maybe
just maybe was getting slightly
complacent about the november
presidential election because the polls
just look
so good for joe biden this is a red
alert
moment for you it should be a wake-up
call to
every one of us that nothing is over
this is going to be a huge fight donald
trump could certainly win we could be
facing four more years of a trump
presidency according to data provided to
axios by
yes the trump campaign and the rnc
republicans have more registered voters
than democrats in some key states
relative
to 2016. and i'll tell you i've looked
at the data and it's a mess
now as a pretext not as a pretext as a
as a disclaimer i think better said
they may be lying so i'm going to give
you the data that axios was given
by the trump campaign and by the rnc
about voter registration
they could be lying if they're lying
great then we'll win by a lot
okay but if they're not lying we need to
take this seriously and that's why this
matters so the point here
is all we can do because we don't know
what the truth is is register every
voter
convince every voter to vote make sure
every vote is counted we've got to work
on this at all levels but
here's what was given to axios
by the trump campaign and the rnc
compared to the numbers that axios was
given by the democratic party and
if this is wrong great but we have to at
least for now assume that this is
accurate
in florida the democratic
registration advantage over republicans
was reduced
by 87 000 registered voters since 2016.
now think back to 2016. trump won
florida by 112 000 votes
okay if indeed now the party
registration advantage
for democrats has shrunk by nearly 90
000 voters
that is almost twice that is almost
equivalent to that would almost double
donald trump's
victory margin in 2016. however
new registrations are favoring democrats
so what this means is you've had
people who move in and out of the state
people who switch
party etc among simply
new registrations democrats are winning
but when you account for all of the
other changes in registration
democrats have actually fallen behind in
florida okay
pennsylvania pennsylvania is a state
that donald trump won by 44 000 in 2016
and the democratic advantage in voter
registration has been reduced
by 133 000
voters since 2016. again trump won by 44
000
democrats relative to republicans have
lost 133
000 voters since 2016. important
among new registrations democrats have a
15 point advantage but again because of
moving
deaths changing
of party etc the advantage has been
reduced by 133 000 in arizona
republicans have taken the advantage in
registered voters over democrats
in iowa republicans have taken advantage
and registered voters over democrats and
in north carolina
the democratic net advantage has shrunk
this is why overwhelming the vote is the
necessary action here if they're going
to suppress the vote well let's
overwhelm the vote so that suppressing
it 0.05 but you know 0.5 or 1 percent
won't make a difference
they win over they win over democrats in
terms of new registrations or in terms
of people who
overwhelm the ballot box right it is
truly the solution here to all of the
problems now another really important
thing
when you look at new registrations
and see the democratic advantage so for
example imagine that in a certain state
the republicans were able to increase
their advantage in terms of party
registration by a hundred thousand
but among new voters who were never
previously registered
democrats registered more new people
my guess is that the new registrants are
more likely to vote because something
got them to register
since the last election so maybe that's
in our
in our corner to our advantage but you
can't assume
anything now there are a few funny
caveats here but again they shouldn't
change our behavior number one
some of the people changing registration
to the republican party
they might be doing it in order to mess
with the republican party we've seen
people
switch to the democratic party to vote
in the democratic primary even though
they have no intention of actually
voting for the democrat in a general
election we've seen it the other way
we don't know for sure but it is
possible that there are people switching
to republican registration
for a variety of different reasons many
of which might not mean they are
necessarily voting for trump in november
we don't know we can't do anything about
it
and again we are evaluating
registration based on the data given to
axios
by the trump campaign and the republican
party they could be lying they lie all
the time it wouldn't be hugely
surprising if they were lying
but we can't know that right now and we
won't know it
until the election if at all so we can't
act on that basis
all we can act on all that we should be
motivated to do
is to keep going and assume nothing
going into november every single voter i
i apologize i know i say this a lot
every single voter should act as if
their vote
could turn your state from one
candidate to the other that's how i will
be voting in massachusetts although
certainly mathematically
it's not going to be the case now let's
dig into vote by mail
this is crazy donald trump has been
continuing to attack vote by mail
while drawing a false distinction of
vote by mail
from absentee ballots while now telling
floridians that they should all vote by
mail so the back story has been that
uh as the coronavirus has raged voting
absentee
has become increasingly important in
terms of safely
voting in november we have never had a
federal election
federal presidential election delayed we
don't plan to do it this time but we
want to do it safely
donald trump has come out very strongly
against vote by mail and we know why we
looked at a poll on monday
which showed that among voters planning
to vote in person two-thirds support
trump
among voters planning to vote by mail
more than 70 support joe biden so the
date is clear it's crystal clear why
trump would oppose vote by mail
then trump has sort of either
deliberately or genuinely you know we
don't know
he's been confused about vote by mail
versus absentee ballots
even though what we are talking about
this year
is expanding absentee ballot access to
whoever wants one not requiring
certain conditions to be met fear of
catching coronavirus
should be a valid reason to vote
absentee often in real time
we started to see over the last 72 to 96
hours
contradictions between what donald trump
is saying and what his press series
press secretary kelly mcinanny has been
saying and yesterday
in the midst of a press briefing during
which kaylee was saying one set of
things about
the fraudulent nature of vote by mail
donald trump tweets out of nowhere
quote whether you call it vote by mail
or absentee voting which sort of implies
that he's recognizing it's the same
thing
whether you call it vote by mail or
absentee voting in florida the election
system is safe and secure tried and true
what florida's voting system has been
cleaned up
we defeated democrats attempts at change
so in florida
i encourage all to request a ballot and
vote by mail
maga or maga i prefer said to say so now
trump is saying
in florida specifically both
vote by mail or absentee which he's
conceding are the same things
are safe in other states where vote by
mail
and absentee ballots are also the same
thing except you won't accept it
only absentee is safe vote by mail is
not safe
other states like nevada who have
decided to expand
absentee ballot access to everybody are
really really bad
but in florida everybody should vote by
mail this is incoherent
there's just no way around it and trump
was asked about this during yesterday's
press briefing
and he came up with some wacked response
about ron desantis is one of the best
governors
now almost everything trump says the you
just reverse it to find out the truth
ron desantis is one of the worst
governors and in fact has overseen one
of
the worst coronavirus responses in the
country but trump's explanation was
uh ron desantis is so great that you can
vote by mail safely in florida
so there's speculation about what the
real reasons might be that donald trump
is saying hey
vote by mail in florida it's good there
but not elsewhere so a few there's kind
of two options and then a third which is
pretty ominous the first
option is very simple trump is concerned
with personal hypocrisy
i know how could that possibly be but
just you know this is the idea
trump knows he voted absentee in florida
he recently changed his residence to
florida and he's being
called out about it so he wants to make
it a state by state
issue and he's saying listen florida's
safe i voted by mail in florida
in nevada it's unsafe he attacked nevada
earlier this week that's the first
possibility
second possibility is there's something
specific about florida that he's seeing
in polls
like i don't believe this idea that it's
fine in florida because it's safe but
not in nevada
what's possible is that there's some
polling data something about florida
demographically maybe you know florida
has the fifth oldest
population in the country maybe the 2016
results
combined with the demographic realities
of florida
make him think i've got old folks whose
votes i need in florida
let me encourage vote by mail in florida
but not in other places that's the
second possibility and always the
it's because of trump what's best for
trump the third possibility
which is ominous is does trump have a
reason to think that ron desantis
this whacked republican governor one of
the worst
in the country does ron desantis have
something planned
in florida where trump knows
that vote by mail will either not hurt
him or will help him
because of funny business that
ron desantis has planned or maybe the
trump campaign has even worked out with
ron desantis
it's conspiratorial there's no doubt um
it would be treasonous it would be
immoral but remember in the year 2000
you know the bush gore
contest and how florida ended up putting
george w bush in office
effectively is what took place could
florida do it again so
what's the solution come on you guys
know
don't let it come down to florida um
make
the results so skewed against donald
trump
that florida is actually irrelevant that
biden would win with florida
or biden would win without florida
that's the way to do it and by the way i
checked out some of the pro-trump
corners of the internet yesterday after
trump being against vote by mail
for months all of these trump enclaves
are now instantly falling and lying and
saying yes safe vote by mail in florida
vote by mail in florida re-elect trump
it's fascinating to watch them
change their stance in an instant pretty
good sign of a cult when you see that
now here's one idea
that i will leave you with instead of
using these terms
vote by mail or absentee voting vote by
mail
and absentee same thing different thing
should we just call it
vote absentee by mail like does that is
that a a linguistic solution to a
political problem that might be able to
head off some of the nonsense about
one versus the other are they the same
are they not i'm voting absentee by mail
everybody should vote absentee by mail
maybe there's something there maybe i'm
very very wrong let me know what you
think
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david
pakman's show coffee for your chemex or
french press or
a david pakman show t-shirt it's all
available
on our website shipping to anywhere in
the world
at davidpakman.com gear don't miss the
bumper stickers too
davidpakman.com forward slash gear
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
some super interesting primary results
from yesterday progressive activist
corey bush has defeated
ten-term u.s congressman lacey clay
in the democratic primary in the first
district in missouri
and this is an interesting seat because
it has actually been in the clay family
since the 1960s bill clay represented
the district for 30 years
then his son william lacy clay
jr was elected in 2001
so it's been since the 1960s that this
seat
has been in the same family in missouri
now back in 2018 corey bush ran against
lacy clay
and lost by 20 points not a small
defeat there for cory bush last night
she won roughly 51 to 49 percent as of
the latest numbers i saw
cory bush is a nurse and an activist and
this is a
pretty similar situation to aoc's
district
in new york city where the winner of the
democratic primary is
overwhelmingly likely to win the general
in november so essentially the
democratic primary
is is really the big election there is a
republican candidate it's anthony rogers
he won the republican primary
uh last night as well and it is you
might be
if you're not familiar with the missouri
first district
you might be surprised to hear that it
is such a safe district for for
democrats
it's an extremely urban district so as
we know in the united states there are
voting differences among religions there
are
voting differences among age voting
differences among race but the urban
rural divide is also
significant and this is a very urban
district and widely expected
to go to cory bush in a similar
situation as that which we saw
with aoc not long ago now
there's an important reminder here about
how you we can't really evaluate the
potential impact of a biden presidency
without taking into consideration the
house and senate now we've talked about
the senate before and with the senate
it's a much more obvious analysis which
is
if republicans can continue to control
the senate
during joe biden's at least first two
years in office if biden were to win
there's going to be a dramatically
smaller number of
even potential big progressive victories
if you have biden in the oval office
a democratically controlled house and a
republican senate
it's going to be a fight it's going to
be obstruction and the amount that can
get done is going to be
much more limited if democrats can take
the senate and keep the house
and joe biden wins you will have a
two-year period during which you could
see
uh some pretty major uh progressive
advancements made
they might not be perfect they might not
be what bernie would do but they would
be significant and notable advancements
in the progressive in the potentially
more progressive house
the effect is more nuanced because what
we're talking about in the house is it's
already democratically controlled every
expectation is that democrats will
retain control in the house of
representatives but
will it move to the left and when corey
bush replaces lacy
lacy clay that is a potential move
to the left for sure and that is a more
nuanced situation
will the bills that make it to biden's
desk
which he will be forced to sign or not
sign
and of course that would be after
conferencing with
the senate assuming democrats take it a
more progressive house
also better positions us to put more
progressive legislation in front of joe
biden
potentially getting him to sign it so
this is a really big deal
and if we do see these two years
of total control by democrats white
house
senate house we're very much getting
ahead of ourselves we're not going to
put the cart before the horse here
you could see one of the greatest
reversals in a two-year period from the
completely
whacked and outrageous white house of
donald trump
with a republican senate that has gotten
so many judges
in appointed in confirmed for life
positions
you could actually see a really big
reversal uh to american politics
would it be what bernie would do if he
was given carte blanche no but that's
not the system we have we have a system
where we have a house
we have a senate uh we we have states
rights
we have a white house and it would be a
very very interesting situation now as
far as cory bush
she supports medicare for all she
supports a green new deal supports
15 minimum wage wants public funding of
elections and takes no corporate pac
money so a very
interesting replacement to the uh uh
cur still incumbent as far as the house
is concerned
uh lacy clay this also this is
maybe one other angle worth touching on
this does suggest that aoc was not an
anomaly
or an anomaly both of course valid
pronunciations
and that this may be a real wave of
replacing some of these more entrenched
legacy democrats
with younger more progressive
alternatives
the effect that they will have much like
in 2010 when the tea party
surfaced and won a bunch of seats
just because they were winning seats
didn't tell us what effect they would
have on the national politics or on the
republican party
we later saw that they certainly uh
became a notable voice in the republican
party and was sort of absorbed into it
now there's a tea party caucus
still an open question what the longer
term effect is
uh of these progressive victories in the
house and much of it will depend again
on the circumstances of who's in the
white house starting in january
and who controls the senate starting in
january and whether you do or don't like
any individual policy from any of these
progressive replacements to legacy
democrats that's less important than the
realization that there is a changing of
the guard happening here
the i don't think that can be denied
anymore the open question that we will
have to answer
over time is what will the effect be on
not just the ideology of the country
but on the policy of the country as well
so listen um how do we even do this
things are getting really ugly in the
progressive media space
and it pains me to have to do this today
but sam cedar has
casually made a disgusting claim
about the david david pakman show and
fired
a shot across the bow about a recent
surge of subscribers
claiming absent any evidence mind you
that somehow bots
that i have presumably used or paid for
are boosting our youtube subscriber
numbers
let me give you a little background last
week by the way this is all a joke just
because i know people
this is all a joke okay last week the
david pakman show hit
nine hundred thousand youtube
subscribers this was a major major deal
for us
and we got from eight hundred thousand
to nine hundred thousand in the matter
of just a few months
and um it was alleged
that i established sort of a race
against
sam cedar to a million subscribers
that's very much untrue i didn't even
know where sam was from the standpoint
of subscribers
what i established last week was a race
against the clock not against anybody
else i said
let's get to a million by election day
okay
now we were not on track to reach that
as of last week we were projected to
reach a million on january 9th
thanks to the last 10 days of people
pounding that subscribe button churning
that subscribe button
uh dremeling the subscribe button you
know all of the battle of
all this stuff uh we were uh updated
to maybe be on track to hit a million by
december 25th
this was apparently brought to sam
cedar's attention
and in the midst of this he has made the
sick vile claim that we are using
bots um check this out
and indeed it turns out we are just a
few thousand subscribers
apart now it is totally plausible that
either of us could get to a million
first and that's great i mean in this
case you know with with trickle-down
taxes a rising tide does not lift all
boats in this case i think a rising tide
does lift all boats
we get cross recommendations on youtube
if more people watch sam
i get more recommendations from his
videos if more people watch
me sam gets more recommendations from my
videos at least presumably
so that's my view but during a call to
sam
yesterday it was disgustingly
suggested by sam that we are using bots
take a look at this very ugly allegation
i appreciate the message uh ronald
reagan uh
let twitter battles die except for uh
for specific people so i appreciate that
yeah one other one other thing uh pacman
is out there
challenging you to a race to a million
um
you know he's really coming after you
and he's pulling away you guys were
basically tied around
90 908 908 000 uh youtube subscribers
he's already at uh 9 12. and
some people on twitter were saying well
yeah that's because
pacman does more videos but that's like
saying the person who runs the race
faster wins and that makes the race
unfair i mean
i don't know he just seems to be
outworking you i smell bots
i smell bots now this is completely
irresponsible for sam to make this
allegation it's actually sick um
and if i were you i'm talking to the 900
and however many thousands
918 000 people in my audience sam's
saying that you don't exist
okay this is the epitome
of depersonalization sam is saying you
you think you just subscribed to my
channel you think you're a person
you don't exist you're a bot you don't
matter it's like you're not even real
um let's watch a little more because it
actually gets worse
so look here here it is right now put
this video up
look folks ronald reagan has just
informed me that
david pakman has taken a lead in our
race to get to a million
subscribers and i
am making a personal appeal to you right
now
hit the subscribe button it's not
necessarily where i'm pointing to i
don't know where it is maybe it's
maybe it's down here or over there but
hit the subscribe button
don't let david pakman steal our valor
thank you uh for the reminder he's he's
he's stolen enough as far as i'm
concerned but also okay
but also yes i think that you two need
to to work out some stakes
um and i was thinking that uh the loser
has to use
uh the winner's promo code in their ad
in their ad spots for
like a month for a month so you would do
the cbd
you would do the cbd farm ad but then
say
coupon code d pacman or whatever it is
no our coupon code is left is best i'm
not doing that
i'll do the sun's out guns out challenge
though
i'll do the sun's outgunner when we wear
it
yeah so sam they're raising the idea of
a sun's out gut uh
sun's out guns out challenge where we
wear tank tops and expose our biceps i
don't know
about that i don't know how much that
resonates with me um but we can't allow
this to happen right i mean after such a
disgusting shot across the bow was fired
we can't just sit back and let them do
this i hope people are with me here and
then by the way
it gets even worse an hour later in the
show look at these dirty
tricks sam for the sub battle i will
make sure to unsubscribe from pacman to
help you in the race you should tell
your subs to do the same
until you hit one million no i don't
want to take the word from pac-man
that's that's darker
you're no roger stone here i'm not i'm
not going to make a call for that
after i just read your call for it so
why would i do it
so that's even grosser sam indirectly
calling for people to unsubscribe from
me without really calling for it right
i don't have to i would never say that
and why would i because the caller just
did or
the text it's disgusting guys so
uh this just as a heads up this is all
fake
it's all a joke the only serious part is
let's get to a million help me get to a
million and sam help everybody
you it's not like voting where you can
only vote once you can vote for
everybody
okay we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 davidp
here's a caller who seems to think trump
is going to prison
hey david jeff from oregon calling
with a little comment on your show
tonight
as always enjoy your show but you were
stating that
there's no way donald trump would ever
go to jail
and if we actually have a free and fair
election
and joe biden is elected there's only
three ways that
that that trump never goes to jail okay
one the intro of the president pence
uh pardons him two
biden pulls and obama and goes oh we're
looking forward we're not looking back
or three during all the legal wrangling
he actually passed away
those are the only three ways that
donald trump does not go to
jail for all the crimes he committed
before his presidency during the
campaign and during his presidency
i just respectfully disagree the the
united states
is not the type of country where
former presidents go to prison and i'm
not arguing that trump has not done
things that would put a normal person in
prison
that is not my argument my argument is
merely
trump is not going to prison that that's
my
prediction maybe i'll be wrong we've got
a great bonus show for you today don't
miss it grab a membership
join pacman.com you will be provided
instant access to the bonus show